seventy-eight years old ascenders
performed well in the early primaries
but later fell behind Biden who has
built a substantial lead in the race for
delegates I wish I could give you better
news but I think you know the truth and
that is that we announce some 300
delegates behind Vice President Biden
and the path toward victory is virtually
impossible so while we are winning the
ideological battle and while we are
winning the support of so many young
people and working people throughout the
country I have concluded that this
battle for the Democratic nomination
will not be successful and so today I am
announcing the suspension of my campaign
let's bring in our correspondent in
Washington Stefon Simmons Stefon how
surprising is Sanders decision not
really surprising actually everybody had
the bets out when this is coming it was
necessary that he did this he couldn't
do he couldn't get the numbers right
this all coming down to meth even if
there were any primaries right now and
even if he one would have won a few and
there are no primaries due to the
coronavirus crisis here in the US as you
all know but if they were some and he
would have won some he wouldn't have the
numbers anymore to really challenge Joe
Biden and I think he came to this
conclusion to now important why because
the timing is the most important here
with him dropping out of the race now
the Democrats can throw all their weight
of support behind Joe Biden that means
the Clintons Hillary Clinton Bill
Clinton the Obamas can now speak out
come out and support and campaign if
they want to and if they're asked to for
Joe Biden and if necessary and that is
the most important thing resulting out
of this decision for Bernie Sanders to
drop out right now but when he began the
race Bernie Sanders was being extremely
well why has he lost so much support I
think that has something to do with
mainstream Democrats thinking about
electability
and Bernie Sanders did not get the
african-american Democratic vote did not
get the older Democratic vote he got a
lot of young people to be very very very
loud and enthusiastic at his rallies
thousands of people really good energy
cetera the problem was though even those
young people did not show up at the
ballot at the primaries and that's why
he lost against Joe Biden on Super
Tuesday for example remember that was a
disaster Joe Biden went through a Super
Tuesday Democratic Super Tuesday like a
steam machine and got almost all states
so for Biden there was no for for
Sanders pardon was no other chance as to
at some point come to grips with the
facts here and that is he cannot beat
Joe Biden in the in the in the
presidential campaign or an in
presidential race 2020 but Bernie
Sanders also spoke of winning the
ideological battle what was that a
reference to that is Mr Sanders been
very proud and rightfully so actually
very proud of his campaign not being
just a campaign he always generated
himself and made this campaign a little
bit more grassroots a grassroot movement
so destroyed there is of course the
debate of how significant this is or
large but again it is a little more than
just a campaign he has support and he
wants the support to sustain for the big
convention in whenever it happens
because that gives him power on topics
Stephan sermons in Washington thank you
so much for that